hello and welcome to this video I'm
going to play some more blitz chess and
I hope the microphone sound issues are
resolved now I put out the sound check
video and people said that it sounded
fine it just needed a bit more gain and
I hope this is now done I changed some
stuff down and hopefully we are good now
so playing a PD boss here Eva gallo
I think thank you it's actually on again
the no doesn't have a name in depth the
leech has had temporarily deactivated
the profile pages but they are on again
yeah no should do this correctly and I
think we're we're doing okay yeah yeah
what is fine now
black should probably trade on v3 Queen
a6 is not so good because of we should
have one that is something that when he
recently had in a game night a sixes the
critical continuation this line and
looking forward to
to test this Bishop c2 I will simply
castle and give up that pawn that's a
really fascinating possibility that I
discovered in my analysis for keep it
simple do you form yeah black should
take this pawn there is no way around
that
Bishop C form is not such a good idea
because if somebody I have no squares
yeah only b5 is available so this is
better and now I I must admit that I
have forgotten precisely what you do so
this looks very normal but I'm not
entirely sure if it is the right square
sometimes even BD 2 is fine
[Music]
the main point that I'm making here with
white is that my attention is to play
rook a1 and before and the night
whenever it moves it will open up the
view on the a pawn and if I can win at a
porn I'm also going to be yeah
pressurizing b7 a lot we will probably
see something of that in this game
because it's very difficult like to
avoid such a scenario something that I
just wondered about is what am i what
what what I'm doing against night before
yam I was just thinking that this could
be an idea but it's probably ultimately
not that great so I'm going here simply
threatening the pawn so a6
yeah and now this is kind of a weird
setup of those pieces so what is the
best way to play this b3 intending
Knight a four could be a thing
I mean b3 intending okay for sorry
here we see why Bishop d2 might might
have been a good alternative
okay I'm going with this move
you
yeah we know the justness one is good
a five is blonde during the night so
this is not going to work and like now
seems to be busted actually more or less
Nancy - could happen what
I will just trade and take be 7 and then
the queenside situation public is more
or less hopeless
yeah yeah it doesn't have another move I
mean I'm not quite sure what he's
thinking about a five look before loses
immediately I only have 92 there's just
no other move available
you
Jim I don't know
you
it just has animals but
takes in a while I know it just adds a
clock went down got a cloned yeah I
don't know don't know where you know
what's at the point is okay
now let's go for a new game a person has
left the site hello
I mean I understand that you sometimes
are frustrated with the game but I mean
you just play the barrel and lost
convincing women nothing special going
on there
okay um playing the Queens gambit here
angling for a row :
this cost you okay this will cost you or
as also this player I cost Jack arute
scheme anyway I'm going to take this
pond Quincy - it's a little bit strange
and dispersion
quite often however white can play those
kind of objectively incorrect gambits
because we are incorrect mm-hmm but they
are often at least somewhat tricky
because white has a central advantage
that same but you have to really try to
get some compensation going if you're
just sitting around you're just a pawn
down and currently white is not really
doing that much in this position so this
being almost a pawn up is
materializing now e5 is a takács and
it's not easily covered
what
so he's what are you telling me that you
play what that's this and then ninety
six is clear idea crazy really
Wow
okay
you
can can I somehow really review it
No I mean I think this is better for
black so I'm going to play this but I'm
so bit stunned
I actually wanted to play Knight takes
e5 and blunder McQueen
this is crazy
really
you
you
you
Knight takes e5 you go check on c4 with
the knight
it's a tough call
I can also take these six and then he
will take on c4
95 yeah this is equal and they have to
be a little bit quicker now
the cheetah again or what what is going
on here I mean this is really strange
what people are doing here or maybe it's
just his bad connection I mean the whole
game is weird like this is typical mo of
playing a [ __ ] opening and then
having some weird tactics and it's no
it's just so strange
okay I'm covering this for the moment
still attacking b2 and I have before
also
[Music]
you
you
so now he runs into a background maid
what an odd game what what the what the
heck is going on here right so strange
could I have refuted this this weird
stuff I just have to check this like
completely refuted so night b5 so
Bishop d2 and now Knight takes e5 is
right okay
yeah I was not here I wasn't so sure but
I actually have this check this is very
very important so the check and then
then the pin and here black wind say
that is really true I have c5 coming
also the way I played it I don't even
have that much like here this is just
nothing I was so irritated over thing
okay so a new game against the vault on
Prokofiev let's go what Sicilian they
play the open con so I'm going to get a
sveshnikov this video is probably going
to be a little bit shorter because I
have a
business call
they don't want to let the other guy
wait but I wanted to get the video done
so that I'm absolutely sure that I make
one for today
yeah this is a fairly normal Sicilian
smash nuke off position Bishop g5 is
always played to keep an eye on the e3
square so that after possible Knights e2
e3 you are able to take it at a
convenient moment and fight form the
control of d5 okay here I'm going to be
six I don't want to take 27 as possible
here too
[Music]
more or less now cannot say I'm forcing
to trade you can go back to f3 which
would okay or this one okay so a couple
of things I can come on let's let's just
try to prove that I equalize with very
simple means and disposition I have
enough control over d5 so there is no
problem at all here
you
the only scenario that is truly
problematic in such in such a position
type is the knight on d5 against a dark
square bishop that is really a problem
if the night comes here there's a bishop
on d8 I mean there is a funny quote by
magnus carlsen that the bishop on d8 is
dominating the night but I have no to
have no source for that quote but it's
what Peter had in nudes and told me once
that that Magnus is on the record with
this but I don't know them actual source
in any case this kind of thing is not a
problem I'm controlling v5 and the c3
pawn is just as weak as the d6 pawn
let's see how white continues to play
the idea is very likely to go c5 and I
have to say that the rook on a six is
indeed a bit of a pain it's annoying to
have this on the board would be good to
trade it for sure
don't have particularly attractive now
something like Queen d7 but that's not
really what you want to do maybe the
Queen is however not badly no he can
actually go c5 then
because I cannot take do to the back
ring
okay so then things are not as
comfortable as a thought
you
I don't have a really good square for
the Queen
huh remarkable
you
yeah once c5 hits it's really annoying
ergo Queen d7 c5 can i play something
there
[Music]
you
I see no we move that's crazy crazy
stuff this is just blind I cannot
believe that this is the simple thing of
c-5 which is so strong
now he's not playing it that's friggin
crazy it's simply not playing in the
movie
okay
maybe he doesn't have to immediately or
something like that but still
you
96 to deform probably what I want
or just to get get the rocks off the
board somehow like Luke c6 but rook c6
is not going to take he's going to play
okay seven I guess and then the whole
thing didn't really do much
you
yeah this is a move that I had that I
was concerned about
you
just trying to trade this down however I
just spotted that he can take and play
and play wook a form oh okay he's I
thought just okay for first
you
you
Oh
you
Queenie to where the threat simply
it'sit's additively easily stop it
is too less to watch out
[Music]
you
you
andrew created crazy what's what what
the heck what weird game like if he has
a combination of very strong moves and
completely ridiculous moves like not
playing c5a is entirely ridiculous I
spent like two minutes and I don't find
something here that's so it's so hard
because I feel this whole play is
strange a form
can hardly be right I mean I probably
just underestimated it because this is
how it so harmless so before yeah of
course I can play before but I thought
that I'm trying to play for a better
position with taking but that's not the
case it seems
often times if you can trade all this
actually the c-3po improves to be weaker
than the six but not here
so this seems to be wrong then yeah this
c4 c5 is immensely immensely annoying I
played this and after C Friday I just
don't have anything okay here c5 just
kills me and he didn't see that for some
reason even after two minutes very weird
and here I probably just shouldn't panic
94 was a bit of a panic move after g6
yeah
g6 I guess you cannot take because of
this you have not before that's the pork
so I shouldn't panic yeah here also yeah
kind of I think this 26 and now we just
plays genius chess right queenie 7
seven ma'am I have to play Quincy eight
and here this is killing me my back rank
was of I was weak
nothing to do so one way to kill me and
I was nicely done it was very strange
that he didn't play c5 these kind of
things always fascinated me because I'm
sitting here for two minutes
the threat is clearly c5 I play this
because I don't find anything and c5 is
a totally obvious killer and he doesn't
do it
very strange
and so the main thing is I should not
wear is that I should not take simply
and play before and then nothing much is
going on okay I think I can go for one
more game
you
f12
got it
you
some people don't want to have a game on
video which is um understandable
I think there's also the amount of odd
behavior and and and things like that um
somewhat increasing over the last weeks
many new
players here on their platform do to
gather current health crisis
so I don't get a gimme 'm that's not
good I don't have that much time
here I got one C to Jimmy and he's got a
high rating
removing c6
okay now this is a playable variation
from black/white is a little bit better
normally but it is not something special
interesting I wasn't aware that this
movers played here
you
you
you
now ninety-two fails to simply Bishop
tanks
you
you
also easy to get a good development
going here
[Music]
ninety-two is still not possible they
don't want to go night in one clearly
you
yeah maybe I have to play this one just
for the moment
you
you
okay so I would definitely like to play
d4 at some point - to open the position
it's not so easy no Queen III and then G
form
get rid of my him someone back with porn
I don't think that I have a problem in
this position because the squared d 4 is
firmly under White's control and as long
as this is the case I can maybe simply
take because I cannot take with the D
pawn okay
just shutting it down
ready for Bishop g4
g-46 would be good
then move the night play Bishop c4 this
is a little bit bit of a fairy tale
[Music]
scenario
what I might get close to that
I can check
yeah it's kind of a standard exchange
sack not something that the subjective
we work now it it's it's playable you
know in a blitz game
I don't think it can work because my
bishop on d5 is simply too strong
[Music]
I mean I might lose the game due to
something stupid that I do with just an
exchange of
you
and it's fairly close disposition err
it's not super easy to convert probably
there's simply no open fire
but we're getting the IR Queen f3 look
he won then he 5 something like that I
need to open up the position of course
make the rooks count
you
preparing me five
he wants to go Bishop d6 I guess
Oh
you
I'd like to
you ready for the smooth
now
look here
I didn't see this one it's a little bit
awkward that I didn't
you
horns
and push
i Scott Queen g5 coming
ash what what the beep
yeah I have lost control I overlooked
this move we should have five and then
throw me off yeah
before it was a fairly simple window for
white and now not so much my king is
just a bit too weak
you
you
okay maybe I'm not losing immediately
it's very difficult to coordinate this
thing here this position
you
marking is just extremely weak
Oh
you
you
I should be reasonably safe on the light
squares
I Ching keeps that bringing pawn now
this game is a real pain
[Music]
you
could afford
- Monday form
no just Hanks
it probably has something better than
hey I can simply take on d2 and you know
cut this check on h1 okay
that's a really annoying loss because
roopd voice is entirely incorrect it's
just an exchange for her nothing I mean
he had to do it because he's already
totally out laid of course like the
alternative is something like that and
after that white is of course clearly
better for white doing this is a little
bit more interesting as an exchange
sacred I don't have to I just have a
huge advantage here Andrew Tafoya is
just this fancy player that doesn't work
yeah maybe I should have waited with
there for a little bit more that is
always tough to say because you want to
use your books I mean but it's not about
an objective evaluation and in any
longer time control is just over yeah
here I I did not see Bishop f5 I really
thought he doesn't have a good move here
anymore and Bishop f5 makes difference
if I play is six which is the
alternative this Bishop stays shut out
on on c8 and is easy it's an easy one
you see that is +4 I didn't see that
this is asan deactivated and now things
get tricky already and fairly quickly
here after Bishop d6 black as bottom
yeah this is an awful position to claim
I'm very certain that I was better again
at some point because he played it badly
but at least I'm okay I'm okay f3 but
it's a blitz game what what can you do
him it's practically speaking terrible
to defend for me so what was the draw
creaform okay yeah I only had some
second some I the main thing is that I
overlooked this Bishop f5 thing if I
play e6 the game is just over as it
should be okay guys thanks for watching
I have to shut it out or stop the video
now because I have to do something
important bye bye
you